[موسيقى]
مساء الخير يعني ايه داعش ومين داعش وفين
داعش ومين واقف ورا داعش اسئله مهمه جدا
تستحق ان احنا نحاول الاجابه عليها مش
احنا بس اللي بنبحث عنها على الاجابات
العالم كله بيسال عن داعش والناس اللي
بتقدم اجابات عن القصه دي عدد مش كبير
تعالوا نشوف كده القصه من الاول نقول مين
هي يا داعش داعش اللي اشتهر بها ما يسمى
ب الدوله الاسلاميه هي اختصار لكلمه
الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام طب
امتى نشا هذا التنظيم اللي اخد اسماء قبل
هذا الاسم وبعد هذا الاسم نقدر نقوله
باختصار انه داعش ليست الا احد تنظيمات
القاعده اللي اسسها اسامه بن لادن واخرين
معاهم من يعني اخرين مع اسامه بن لادن في
اواخر الثمانينات وتحديدا ظهر للوجود بشكل
رسمي في
1988 ظهر فين ظهر في افغانستان لما كانوا
بيقوموا بدعم من الولايات المتحده والدول
العربيه ومنها مصر والسعوديه ودول
الخليج الروس اللي كانوا محتلين افغانستان
ودي قصه ثانيه قصه طويله طيب علاقه
القاعده ايه بداعش داعش باعتبارها احد
تنظيمات القاعده ظهرت وانتعشت بشده بعد
دخول غزو الامريكان للعراق في
[موسيقى]
2003 وقتها ظهر ممثل للقاعده اسمه ابو
مصعب الزرقاوي وهو
[موسيقى]
اردني هذا الرجل قاد
تنظيم القاعده في العراق وسمي وقتها
بالقاعده في بلاد الرافدين حتى هذا الحين
لم تكن هناك اي مشكله القاعده هي الموجوده
التي عرفناها وعرفها الناس عملت 11
[موسيقى]
سبتمبر هي نفسها القاعده اللي كانت موجوده
في العراق وبيق قائد ميداني اسمه ابو مصعب
الزرقاوي ابو مصعب الزرقاوي ظل يقود
التنظيم حتى 2006 حين قتل في في غاره
امريكيه لكن قبل ان يقتل ابو مصعب
الزرقاوي كان دب الخلاف بينه وبين قاده
القاعده اسامه بن لادن وايمن الظواهري
الدكتور ايمن الظواهري اللي هو
يعني احد قاده القاعده المعروفين لانه ابو
مصعب الزرقاوي كان ابتدى ياخد تنظيم
القاعده الى مستوى اخر من
التطرف مش بس يكتفي
بمقاتلين او من غزو القوات التي غزو
وحلفائها من من غزو العراق ولكن اشتبك في
معارك داميه جدا مع الشيعه باعتباره سني
فحول فكره الجهاد كما يعتقد اسامه بن لادن
وايمن الظواهري ضد الغرب الذي يريد ان
يحتل العالم الاسلامي الى مشكله كبيره جدا
والى فخ كبير جدا وهو مقاتله الشيعه اللي
بيعتقد ان هم
بيصروا الامريكان والغزاه وهم اكثر خطرا
على الاسلام من هؤلاء الغزه طيب قتل ابو
مصعب الزرقاوي فارسلت القاعده المركز
الرئيسي للقاعده اللي بيرقصه بنلادن وايمن
الظواهري بديلا له وهو ا ا
شخص اسمه يوسف الدرديري
وسمي كنيه كده بابو حمزه المهاجر ابو حمزه
المهاجر اسس هناك الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق 2006 اتولد هذا التنظيم في العراق
وكان ده عباره عن تكتل لمجموعات كثيره من
الجماعات اللي كانت بتقاتل في العراق
لاحظوا ان المجموعات دي كانت مختلفه عن
المجموعات اللي قتل روس في افغانستان لان
دول اتولدوا في بيئه اكثر عنفا بشده ا وهي
بيئه اللي تولدت عن احتلال الامريكان
للعراق بل ان هم كان لهم طموح في اقامه
اماره اسلاميه في الفلوجه في
2004 في كل الاحوال انا بشير ده لان نوعيه
المقاتلين اللي جم سواء كانوا عراقيين او
اجانب وفدوا الى العراق كانوا اكثر ميلا
وعنفا من سابقيهم في افغانستان ظل ابو
حمزه المهاجر او يوسف الدردي قائدا لما
يسميه ب الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق اللي
هو برض احد روافد القاعده لغايه 2010 حين
قتل في 2010 جاء احد اتباعه او احد نوابه
وهو ابو بكر
البغدادي
وتولى الدوله تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق اللي هو تحول فيما بعد الى داعش
ومن داعش الى الدوله الاسلاميه او الخلافه
الاسلاميه اللي اعلن عنها في 29 يونيو
2014 بعد ان استولى على اراضي شاسعه جدا
من سوريا ومن العراق بحيث اصبح الخليفه
الجديد ابو بكر البغدادي اللي ما بنعرفش
عنه معلومات كثيره بيسيطر لاول مره لاول
مره بالنسبه لشخص جهادي يسيطر على تخوم
على مساحه شاسعه جدا تبدا من تخوم العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد الى تخوم العاصمه السوريه
دمشق وله قوات او له نفوس من الحدود
الاردنيه الى الحدود التركيه ولديه تحت
امرته عشرات الالاف من المقاتلين بيدين له
بالولاء ده خلاف عشرات الجماعات ما بين
كبيره ومتوسطه صغيره في انحاء العالم زي
مثلا بوكو حرام في نيجيريا زي ولايه سيناء
في مصر
زي زي جماعات زي جماعات كتيره موجوده في
شرق اسيا كل هذه الجماعات اللي بتدين لابو
بكر البغدادي بتمنه قوه ونفوذا ده خلاف
طبعا ما يسمى بالخلايا النائمه اللي
موجوده في دول كثيره واللي لما بتعمل
عمليات ارهابيه بيعلن التنظيم انه مسؤولا
عنها فهذا التنظيم لاول مره في التاريخ
يكون لهذا لتنظيم اللي بيرقصه ابو بكر
البغدادي كل هذا النفوس الذي لم يتمتع به
حتى اسامه بن لادن قبل مقتلي في
2011 التنظيم لاول مره لاول مره انا بقول
مقارنه بتنظيمات جهاديه يملك كل عناصر
القوه تقريبا بتتمثل في المال اللي بياتيه
من تجاره النفط اللي بياخدها من مصافي
النفط تحديدا السوريه وببيعها في السوق
السودا اللي غالبا بيتم عن طريق الاراضي
التركيه والسنا اسره
الاتراك وعن طريق
تجاره الفديه يعني يختطف رهائن ثم يطلب
فدن مقابل اطلاقهم
وفضلا عن الاموال التي استولى عليها حين
احتل مدنا سوريا وعراقيه باكملها واستولى
على بنوكها ومؤسساتها وثرواتها وطبعا كل
تجاره الاثار كل
تجاره الاراضي و ومصادر الثروه في الاراضي
التي استولى عليها ده من حيث الفلوس من
حيث السلاح استولى التنظيم على كميات ضخمه
جدا من الاسلحه اهمها الاسلحه التي استولى
عليها حين دخل مدنا عراقيه وتركها بمنتهى
السهوله قوات الجيش العراقي في ظروف غامضه
ما زالت موضع
تحقيق هذه الاسلحه تقدر بحوالي 15 مليار
دولار هي قيمه الاسلحه التي انفقها مش
التي انفقها التي امد بها الامريكان الجيش
العراقي طبعا باموال عراقيه 15 مليار
دولار لم تفد لم تفد الجيش العراقي او لم
يستفد منها العراقيون اي شيء سو انهم
تخلوا عن الجزء الاكبر منها حين هجم عليهم
الداعشيون يتبقى العنصر الثالث خلاف المال
والسلاح وهو الكوادر والجنود وهؤلاء ياتون
له من كل حدب وصوب من كل الجنسيات عشرات
الالاف من الاجانب الاجانب يعني خلاف
العراقيين اللي بياتو من مصر
والشيشان وا باكستان واوروبا والولايات
المتحده وطبعا شرق اسيا كل هؤلاء اتوا
خلال الفتره الماضيه وما زالوا يتدفقون من
كل حدود العراق وسوريا وكان المنفذ التركي
منفذ رئيسي لدخول
هؤلاء المقاتلون هؤلاء المقاتلين ابو بكر
البغدادي اللي ما بنعرفش عنه معلومات
كثيره سو انه من عائله
السمرائي في العراق وانه درس في احدى
الجامعات العراقيه
وانه لم يكن يحمل سلاحا او ما عرفش عنه اي
خلفيه عسكريه سوى انه بدا يحمل السلاح بعد
ان دخل الامريكان العراق في يوم مشؤوم من
عام 2003 وزج به في السجن مثل كثيرين وقيل
ان هو كان في سجن ابو غريب وفي نفس السجن
ده التقى عدد كثير
من العراقيين اللي شكلوا فيما بعد او
كانوا ساعدوه فيما بعد في تشكيل
في دعم القاعده ايام ان كانت قاعده ثم في
في دعم طموحه في ان يكون خليفه للمسلمين
ومن بين هؤلاء احد ضباط العراقيين اللي
كان اسمه سمير الخليفاوي واللي سمي اظن
بحجي بكر حجي بكر دوت اللي كشفت عنه اوراق
تحقيق مهم جدا نشرته مجله ديرش بيكل في
ابريل 2015 هو احد ضباط المخابرات الجويه
العراقيه واللي تم تسريحه من الجيش
العراقي بعد دخول الامريكان العراق ولانه
كان شديد الغضب زي كثير جدا عشرات الالاف
من الضباط العراقيين على بسبب احتلال
بلدهم من ناحيه وبسبب قطع ارزاقهم من
ناحيه تانيه حب
انه ينتقم من الامريكان بانه ينضم الى
الجهه الاقوى وهي المقاومه اللي بتحمل
صبغه اسلاميه وكان مع ابو بكر البغدادي في
سجن ابو غريب وبالفعل هذا الرجل دعمه طبقا
لهذه الاوراق في
2010 وساعد في اختيار ابو بكر البغدادي ان
يكون اميرا لهذا التنظيم لاكثر من سبب
اهمهم انه اذا تولى احد القوميين او
البعثيين قياده التنظيم او ظهر في الصوره
دوت هيحرق التنظيم من موارد ضخمه جدا
تتمثل في الكوادر الراغبه في القتال تحت
رايه جذابه وهي رايه استعاده الخلافه
الاسلاميه مقاتله اعداء دا الاسلام ده غري
الناس ياتوا من كل حدب وصوب اما القتار
لتحرير العراق فقد يذب بس فقط المقاتلين
الراغبين في تحرير بلدهم وبالتالي تم
اختيار ابو بكر البغدادي لهذا السبب اذا
كان الكلام ده دقيق او كان الكلام اللي
نشرته دير شبيجل لم يكن دقيقا في كل
الاحوال هذا لا يغير من حقيقه واضحه ان
تنظيم داعش الموجود الان او ما يسمى بخ
خلافه
داعش استفاد
من عده عناصر شديده للقوه اولها الفراغ
الشديد جدا الموجود في العراق نتيجه ضعف
القوات العراقيه وعدم رغبه القوات المحتله
وهي الولايات المتحده قبل انسحابها من
العراق في مواجهه في انها ترسل جنودها على
الارض بل ان هي ساعدت بعد كده في
الاستفاده من وجود هذا الداعش لاحداث
توازن يطول الكلام عنه فهناك فراغ
والطبيعه تكره الفراغ فملا داعش الفراغ
الامر الثاني انه استفاد من عنصرين وجود
عشرات الالاف من الشباب المتحمس الذي
يعتقد ان الاسلام الصحيح هو الجهاد دفاعا
عما يعتقد انه صحيح الدين لاقامه ما يعتقد
انه هو النظام السليم وهو الخلافه
الاسلاميه هؤلاء متحمسون و ويوفرون وقودا
رائعا للحرب والمعارك يضاف الى عنصر هذا
الحماس الخبارات الكبيره التي تم تسريحها
في خطوه شديده الخطا عندما دخل الاحتلال
العرا الامريكي العراق وتم تسريح الجيش
العراقي فهؤلاء يملكون خبرات كبيره جدا
حين يكون لديك الخبرات والجنود يعني
الجنرالات والجنود والسلاح
والبترول والمال فانت لا يمكن الاستخفاف
بيك سؤال المطروح دائما عند كل الناس وفي
كل المناقشات هل هذا الداعش هي صنيعه
الغرب وصنعه المخابرات الغربيه وانا بقول
هنا المخابرات الغربيه لان احنا بنسمع
ققول لك اسرائيل ونسمع طبعا الولايات
المتحده ده كالعاده طبعا ما حدش بيتكلم عن
تركيا ولا السعوديه ولا غيرها لان دايما
الجذاب في الحديث خاصه حين نتحدث بفكر
نظريه المؤامره هي الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل والبريطانيين ويعني اعوانهم واقع
الامر انه الكلام على هذا النحو له بعض
الوجاهه لكن في نفس الوقت فيه كثير من
المبالغه القاعده الولايات المتحده لم
تخلق الفكر المتطرف الذي استندت اليه
القاعده بكل اشكالها سواء كانت القاعده
التي اسسها اسامه بن لادن في اواخر
الثمانينات او التي احياها قاد مختلفون
اخرهم اخرهم ابو بكر البغدادي في العراق
ولا حتى جبهه النصره محمد ا جبهه النصر
لشيخ محمد الجولاني ولا غيرهم فكر المتطرف
موجود في كتب التراث وهولاء يعتمدون عليه
لكن دور الولايات المتحده واعوانها واضح
في امرين
قليين ان اخطائها وعدوانها وجشع هي من مهد
الطريق لقيام هذه التنظيمات الرهيبه علينا
ان نتذكر انه لم يكن هناك وجود للقاعده
قبل ان يدخل الاتحاد السوفيتي الى
افغانستان في بدايه في اواخر السبعينات 79
وحين دخل السوفيت الى افغانستان محتلا سعه
الولايات المتحده بدعم خليجي وعربي ومنها
مصر والسعوديه وباكستان وكل الدول
الاسلاميه الحليفه للولايات المتحده في
دعم هؤلاء المجاهدين وارسالهم الى افغان
ستان بهدف اسقاط الاتحاد السوفيتي وقد كان
فقامت القاعده باسلحه الامريكان واجهزتهم
واجهزتهم الاستخباراتيه امريكان طبعا
وحلفائهم وباموت الخليجيين وبكوادر من كل
الدول الاسلاميه والقاعده الجديده في
العراق او ما يسمى الان بداعش او الدوله
الاسلاميه لم تقم لها قائمه الا ان بعد ان
احتل الامريكان العراق في 2003 ثم ان
لعبوا بعد ذلك على المشاعر وعلى المص
وعلى المصالح الطائفيه ما بين العراق وما
بين الشيعه فا اخطاء العراق فا اخطاء
الامريكان
وا استعمارهم للدول الاسلاميه خلق هذا
الشعور الكاسح بالظلم والرغبه في المقاومه
فهذا عن دور الامريكان من ناحيه والامر
الثاني ان الامريكان حين قامت هذه
التنظيمات الشيطانيه لم يتوانوا ابدا عن
محاوله استغلالها للدفاع عن مصالحهم ازاي
وليه دي قصه كبيره تستحق منا حلقه اخرى ان
شاء الله واشكركم والى لقاء اخر